all the people that I've coached all
have different Talent skills and
abilities what's the one they all have
the ability to stay present the ability
to stay in the fight to have not quit
you think well that's not a big deal
really because as I've been talking
millions of people made the decision to
quit on their dreams just as I've been
talking to you the rest of the day
Millions more will tomorrow Millions
more every day literally millions of
people quit on one of their dreams their
dream relationship their dream business
their dream body so quitting has become
the number one Habit in the world by
people that end up losing